for more on the rising prices gas prices
are just part of it an overall price
increase and now the federal reserve is
trying to slow those price increases by
hiking interest rates by a quarter of a
percentage point it's the first increase
since 2018 and for more on that let's
bring in cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger with how that could affect
consumers like the people watching at
home it's a little confusing because
prices are going up and to make them go
down you raise interest rates right
because we just want to slow down the
pace of borrowing and spending and so
this will directly impact pretty much
everyone the good news first savers you
could start to see a little bit more and
i say a little bit more in interest
rates when you look at your savings
you're checking your money market your
short term cds
borrowers however are going to pay more
to service their debt the most direct
impact credit cards you're going to see
those interest rates start to rise new
car loans will start to rise but you
know the amounts aren't that much so
it's a few dollars a month and i think
that's important small business loans
can be more expensive variable mortgage
rates can be more expensive so borrowers
it's going to cost you more to service
your debt uh what about car loans and
new mortgages well i think in new
mortgages the thing that's really
important is it doesn't key off of the
actual rate that the fed controls so
it's a longer-term interest rate the
10-year treasury those rates have
already started to go up if you look at
mortgage rates right now we're at about
four and a quarter percent or so for a
30-year fixed-rate mortgage and that's
up a full percentage point from a year
ago now that may slow down the hot
housing market but it's going to make it
more expensive to buy a home it was
interesting we'll go ahead go ahead well
i was gonna say the fed they voted on
this it was an eight to one vote and the
one no vote wanted actually a higher
increase so it seems like this is the
beginning of yet more hikes absolutely
the fed also releases projections about
how they think the economy is doing and
where they think interest rates are
going next and according to fed
projections they're looking at another
six quarter point interest rates
increases this year that will bring us
up to just under two percent and another
four or so next year so we are going to
see interest rates broadly rise pretty
quickly over the next couple of years i
want to go back to gas prices i was in
la recently and the gas prices in some
places were over seven dollars still and
people say look i gotta drive i gotta
get to work i gotta get to school et
cetera et cetera is there anything
anything consumers can do to handle the
gas prices or protect themselves
i think this is where consumers have to
do something because the fed cannot
actually
pinpoint gas prices on this they can try
to slow things down but as you said
people have to drive so what you need to
think about is this okay i've gotta
drive maybe i can carpool fine but maybe
i should be paying cash because you can
save five or ten cents a gallon to pay
cash maybe i should use regular gas
filling up on mondays and fridays
theoretically should actually save you a
little bit of money and note to very bad
drivers your aggressive speeding and
braking
that is very bad for fuel consumption
and fuel efficiency so ease up on the
highway regular gas if your car says you
have to use premium i don't know i i
fall i'm a direction follower so i they
if they say to do if they save premium i
think i should do premium but a lot of
people tell me it's kind of bunk i like
there's no speeding uh yeah
you can't make that promise a lot of
people are saying i like the day you
said about filling up on mondays yeah
mondays and fridays and paying in cash
yep jill always great to have you expert
analysis as always thank you very much